the day
thanks for coming uh we have nasheed
vishnoin from yale he's gonna tell us
about optimization and sampling under
continuous synergy
uh thanks uh for the introduction thanks
for the uh uh sticking out it's towards
the end of the boot camp and we already
heard two really great talks today about
the role symmetries play
in computational problems uh in this
talk uh which is a two-part talk uh
the second one will be given by jonathan
leak we are going to be looking at
optimization and sampling problems
under continuous symmetries
and the first part of the talk which i'm
going to give is going to give you some
simple examples
and also speculate about why symmetries
arise and
and and also show you a little bit in
the forward in the future uh you know
what to expect in jonathan's talk
i should just point out that uh jonathan
and i just wrote up a survey on our
talks it's uh available on the archive
now in case you want to look at
uh more details and the talks are based
on primarily on these
uh on the survey
so it's a lot of details which i might
skip or jonathan might skip would be
there in these uh notes
okay so uh so what are symmetries uh so
so symmetries you know have been uh you
know humans have been fascinated with
symmetries for a very long time i'll
just you use a quote from hermann vial
which which kind of succinctly
summarizes uh symmetries uh
a thing is symmetrical if there is
something you can do to it so that after
you have finished doing it it looks the
same as before
so this is one
one way you can think about symmetries
to give some examples we have already
seen many but
let me just give a few more examples
some basic ones so
uh very simple ones so you can you can
think of a polynomial
uh in variables x1 to xn
which is
x1 squared plus dot dot plus xn square
this is a polynomial which is uh an
example of a symmetric polynomial
permuting its variables
uh does not change the value it does not
change the polynomial
uh perhaps the audience here is also
familiar with
uh you know sets like the boolean
hypercube which has these symmetries uh
in coordinates
and i guess uh going back uh
thousands of years
people realize symmetries of objects
like squares which you know you can
rotate the square
by 90 degrees 180 degree and so on it
doesn't really change
[Music]
the square itself
so this is a continuous object a square
is a continuous object which has all
these discrete symmetries
so sphere which is also a continuous
object has this
continuous set of symmetries you can
rotate it by an arbitrary amount and it
still doesn't change it remains
invariant
perhaps more relevant to this talk are
matrices and in particular uh
matrices which are
complex and hermitian so this is just
[Music]
the complex cousin of symmetric matrices
which we are all familiar with
and we can look at the eigenvalues of
such matrices so we know that
eigenvalues are all real for such
matrices
if i
conjugate these matrices by unitary
matrices the eigenvalues don't change
so
if you are for instance interested in
the eigenvalues of a matrix you expect
symmetries to creep in so these are some
very very basic examples of
where discrete and continuous symmetries
play a role
i guess
this is not a talk about the role of
symmetries in physics and mathematics
but i would be
i miss if i did not point out the great
and major roles which have played both
in physics and mathematics
in particular symmetries have guided the
search of fundamental laws of physics uh
i guess we are all familiar with uh
things like special relativity and
general relativity these are all arrived
at through symmetry principles of
various type whether symmetry of space
symmetry of time symmetry of reference
frames
and so on
and
symmetry in physics gives rise to
conservation laws uh which was
discovered by emmy norther
um
and and and and so whenever you see a
conserved quantity uh physicists try to
look for
uh potentially hidden symmetries in the
laws of physics there's a beautiful
article in the quantum magazine
uh which you can look at this picture is
from there
i should also mention that a talk i gave
a couple of days ago on hamiltonian
monte carlo
even though i did not use the word
symmetry
i did talk about conservation laws like
conservation of uh
the hamiltonian or the conservation of
the volume these are all consequences of
northern's theorem and the
symmetries of hamiltonian dynamics
that
were kind of implicit in my exposition
in mathematics uh
continuous symmetries which are encoded
by league groups
are extremely central to many many
branches of mathematics and i guess you
saw in rv stock
all these connections
that he and his group have made
are are not completely accidental
um
there are many many connections that
exist uh even to discrete objects like
combinatorics and you'll see
why even though
we may focus on continuous symmetries uh
in the end discrete symmetries arise
very naturally so that's a theme that
you will see in this talk arising a
couple of times
so uh uh so so coming back to this
workshop uh which is about uh
the semester which is about optimization
and sampling
so i should mention that uh symmetries
uh
do play a role in optimization and
sampling in particular coming up with
efficient algorithms for problems
which are
intrinsically optimization and sampling
problems
there is a growing body of work and here
i present just a very very partial list
starting with uh some works of barbie
knock
uh blacker man in 2003
uh these objects called orbitops in case
you haven't heard of so these are orbits
of objects under group act sorry convex
also orbits
under group actions
so for example you could look at
let's say
you know a spanning tree in a graph and
you can apply certain uh you can permute
the edges by some symmetry group so you
get a bunch of discrete objects you take
the convex help and you start getting
very interesting polytopes for example
you can obtain the tsp polytope in this
manner and so on
so this is an interesting area of
study uh uh
both for discrete groups and continuous
groups uh interestingly it also has
connections with spectrohedral uh
representations so arbitops
often are not convex they are convex
bodies but they are not polytopes and
one may ask if you can represent them in
in some interesting manner
and some very beautiful and deep results
uh
uh more recent results for example by
covert show that these objects have
spectrohedral representations so i'm
pointing it out because there is a lot
of work in
optimization and theoretical computer
science concerning spectrohedra
then i guess we saw a whole bunch of
works
starting with the work of ger gurwitz uh
olivia and victor sun in 2016
on a variety of connections and
algorithms between optimization
complexity theory and invariance
and so really amazing connections
specifically uh to
between complexity theory and uh you
know optimization as avi's uh talk
pointed out
and uh more recently uh so with jonathan
and colin we have been looking at
various optimization and sampling
problems over
symmetric manifolds such as unitary
orbits which i'm going to explain and
these have also end up having a variety
of connections starting from interior
point methods in optimization
to problems in statistics machine
learning differential privacy quantum
inference and so on
so um
there is uh there is something to be
said about
the role symmetries are
have been playing in the last few years
in designing
optimization and sampling
algorithms
so let me start with a very basic
question which i'm afraid i will not be
able to answer to the satisfaction of
the audience but i'll try anyways so why
do symmetries arise
so um in in a very uh very succinctly i
would say that you know symmetries arise
because the functions that we might be
optimizing
encode usually some physical or
geometric quantities
for instance these could be
distances inner products volumes
determinants and so on
and uh
and as we know that you know often we
are working with in continuous domains
with things like vectors matrices and
tensors
and these objects themselves represent
some geometric spaces and there is not
necessarily a unique way to represent
when i mean use the word representation
here it's not in the sense of
representation theory but just in the
ordinary english way
that we choose to represent physical
objects using
uh degenerate objects like vectors
matrices and tensors and as a
consequence when we optimize uh
functions of these
these over these
these you know these objects
uh symmetries and invariants arise very
naturally so i'll give you a very
trivial example which nevertheless makes
this point so consider this function uh
x1 to xn of x1 to xn where xi's let's
live in some euclidean space
and we are interested in the function
which is if it just measures the
pairwise distance squared
so a couple of
things that you may note is that
if i translate each vector x1 by some
other vector c
so each vector is translated by the same
vector c
the function doesn't change
similarly if i rotate each vector x i
with the same rotation matrix so q is a
rotation matrix
then also the function doesn't change
besides a function the domain itself
might have symmetries so here is an
example which will come up in this talk
which is the complex unit sphere
so this is nothing but the set of
n complex numbers whose magnitude square
sums up to 1.
so
this has
this has
the following type of symmetry if you
take a unitary matrix u
so just to kind of quickly recall a
unitary matrix is a matrix which is
you know if you multiply it with its
conjugate
[Music]
transpose its identity
okay so its
rotation matrix is something if it's
it's a real matrix if you multiply it
with its transpose its identity
so if i look at a action of the unitary
matrix on this complex sphere defined as
just take every point on this complex
inner sphere and pre-multiply it with
this uh
interior matrix i get back the sphere
so this is uh yeah this is this is a
a very
simple explanation but i guess the big
point here is the following
that first of all these symmetries form
a group and this is where algebra comes
in
okay
so you can take two vectors c1 and c2
and first translate by c1 and then
translate by c2
and you're going to get a new vector c1
plus c2 which will also belong to this
group of symmetries
similarly you can take a unitary matrix
u1 and take another unitary matrix you
to first apply u1 and then apply u2 so
the product of u2 u1 is also a unitary
matrix
and
a set of all unity matrices actually
composed under this multiplication they
form a group and so they have some
algebraic structure
but that's not it uh if that was it
wouldn't be having this talk actually so
so what is more interesting is that
these set of objects like the set of
unitary matrices or the set of vectors
well instead of vector case it's obvious
that this is just the space the the
group here is just the set of all
vectors in rd
so rd is uh the euclidean space it has a
huge amount of structure in particular
it's the most simple example of a
manifold
the unitary group which is the
collection of all unitary matrices also
has a manifold structure and the moment
you have a manifold structure uh well
it's much more than that it's in fact
even an algebraic variety but i'm not
going to go into that direction in this
talk but the moment you have an uh
manifold structure you can do
uh calculus and analysis on this
so really algebra and analysis kind of
marry together in this
in these kinds of problems and the right
mathematical uh object that arises when
you have a group structure which is
which also is a manifold and and these
two things are compatible with each
other is what is called a d group so
while we may hide away from trying to
understand lead groups which is what i'm
going to do in this talk it becomes
absolutely necessary
to understand lead group theory
to to understand the significant
generalizations of the results that i'm
going to talk about
and also
to
uh
to to really even understand why the
proofs that i'm going to present at this
talk are even
the even uh i mean they will look
mysterious
so i'll take a pause before i go into
the example so i'm going to cover in
this talk to see if anybody has a quick
question
okay so so that in this talk i'm going
to look at two
pretty simple examples uh to make this
point
so the first one is this well-known
optimization characterization of the
minimum eigenvalue problem so given an n
cross and hermitian matrix a
let's say the eigenvalues are ordered
lambda 1 less than lambda 2 and so on
um
the basic theorem in linear algebra
tells you that
or this kind of variational
characterization of the smallest
eigenvalue
is that if we
minimize
this quadratic form
we start we we conjugate transpose av
over the domain of vectors v which
ranges over the complex unit sphere then
the answer to this problem is the
smallest eigenvalue of the matrix a
there are
many many proofs on this theorem
but i'll present one which is
particularly illustrative and
generalizes heavily
in the sampling world i'm going to talk
about a related problem
which is which you can view as some kind
of a robust version of this optimization
problem but instead of outputting the
minimum
you try to sample from of the gibbs
density corresponding to this function b
star av
so the problem is the following again
you're given a matrix a with eigenvalues
lambda 1 to lambda n
and i would like to sample
from this density e to the minus v star
av
where v is on the complex unit sphere
and in particular i'll focus on a
related problem of integrating which is
really just computing the partition
function of this density over the
complex unit sphere so this is a measure
on the complex unit sphere
this
i'm not sure how many people have seen
this result this is not at all obvious i
mean unlike this which i expect all the
audience members to know
this one is more mysterious
uh surprisingly this integral over this
continuous object ends up having uh some
i mean a very small
uh formula
and which is exact
okay
so
it's written in terms of eigenvalues
because everything here is invariant
under unitary transformations or
conjugation by unitaries
so we're going to see proofs of both of
these theorems
in this talk
but the first question you might ask is
okay you know you gave up uh you talked
about symmetry so so where are the
symmetries here
so to start seeing that uh let's define
this set p sub 1
which is
the set of all matrices which are
obtained as follows
so you you fix this matrix which i call
e sub 1
which is nothing but
the following matrix it has exactly one
entry which is non-zero which is the one
comma one entry and all the other
entries are zero so i call this e1
and
what you can look at is the conjugation
of this matrix e1
with all possible n cross and unitary
matrices
so this is a set
in fact this is an example of an orbit
under the action conjugation action of
the unitary group of this matrix e1
uh this is uh
this is a non-convex set so i mean i
should mention i probably forgot to
mention that these are this problem is a
non-convex optimization problem
okay so this function i mean this this
set is not convex
and in general when a is not positive
semi-definite this function is also not
x
okay so so this p1 is uh
is not a is not a convex set
and yet uh
uh we can i mean okay so the first thing
we're going to do is just just write
these theorems rewrite these theorems
uh with respect to this domain p1
because they are both
either optimizing or sampling something
from this
so the the so the first theorem which is
about this minimum eigenvalue can be
reformulated as
saying
that we want to minimize a linear
a linear function
over this orbit p1
and the linear function is
the frobenius inner product of a and x
so we are optimizing a linear function
over a non-convex
[Music]
object
so why is that the case because well
okay so
so this is you can rewrite this in a
this quantity as a forbinious inner
product bv star
and vv star is a rank one matrix a rank
one projection matrix and
and this is the set of all rank and
projection matrices so while i don't
prove this formally it's not too
difficult to see that
there is a one-to-one mapping between
the complex unit sphere and p1 they're
not the same objects
but there is a one two one mapping and
this one to one mapping also gives you
some mapping between measures through
push forward match
so uh for theorem two you can now look
at this exponential density so this is
now a linear function
so it's an exponential density
over this object p1 so this integral now
is our p1
and and and our goal would be to prove
this theorem
so the proof strategy uh in both of
these cases at a very high level works
as follows so there will be some
non-convex object okay
which i illustrate using the boundary of
the sphere
the first step would be to convert the
problem whether it's optimization or
sampling to
some kind of a convex polytope which
here is just the probability simplex
and subsequently we will
further go from the polytrope to some
discrete object
okay in this case
here just ascend the symmetry group
but just pictorially i mean this is what
you're going to see happen two times in
this talk
that we started off from uh
on some non-convex but symmetric
non-convex set
we translated the problem to a
to a polytope and then from a polytope
we go to a
to a discrete set
so this also illustrates a very
beautiful connection between discrete
and continuous symmetries
and the part two of this
two part lectures
will
will introduce a right
notation and definitions that we need to
even make this stuff
uh
formal
and present the generalizations of these
two theorems
that i will speak about
any questions about the
[Music]
the results before i
so the rest of the talk is going to be
uh roughly divided into two parts in the
first part we are going to be talking
about the proof of theorem one and in
the second part we're going to be giving
a proof of theorem two
and then we'll conclude with some
remarks
yeah
are you thinking of theorem one is like
a limiting case of theorem two or
something like this
uh just wondering the connection that
that's right so yeah i think uh so so
you can put another i mean yeah so so
there is a
there is a
uh
yeah if i put in like a temperature here
and and let the uh you know temperature
go to
uh you know i think it's
yeah to zero then uh then
you start getting things like this
yeah
so so that's a very general connection
between optimization and sampling
if you want to i mean you can always go
from sampling to optimization by
introducing a temperature
and then and take a limiting value of
that temperature
yeah i should mention that this theorem
makes sense only when all the lambdas
are distinct
but you can generalize it
once you know the multiplicities of the
eigenvalues it's not too difficult
okay so i'll continue with the proof of
the first theorem
so the proof will be in this slide
itself and in the next slide we are
going to talk about
the generalization or are heading and
start heading towards the generalization
of this theorem but first let's look at
the proof of this
so recall that what we would like to
prove
is um
the following
that we have this uh
unitary orbit of
this diagonal matrix with just one in
the one comma one entry and zero
everywhere else
and we have this linear function that
you would like to optimize over this
unitary orbit
the first thing we can do is to unwind
this unitary orbit and phrase the
problem just as
a problem optimization problem over the
unitary group
and that's exactly so this is just by
just
decoding what it means to be an element
of p1 an element of p1 is exactly
a matrix of the form u even u star where
u belongs to unitary
so let's uh uh you know because there
are just so many unitaries involved uh
let's try to kind of also simplify the
matrix a a little
bit so one thing we'll do is to first
write down a
the spectral decomposition of a
as another unitary w
times a diagonal which consists of its
eigenvalues
times the unitary star
the same unitary star
so this follows from a spectral
decomposition theorem
that you can do this
and then we can just plug instead of a
w the wdw star
here
okay so that's
uh step one
uh we can use the fact that inner
products are invariant the frobenius
inner product is invariant and the
conjugation by unitary is to move all
the unitaries to the to the left hand
side here
and
we get something like this
we know that the set of unitary uh the
set of unitaries forms a group
so u star w is also a unitary
we call it v
so the problem reduces
to
the following
equivalent problem that minimize
over all unitary matrix matrices
v such that v d v star the the inner
product of i mean the frobenius in the
product of v d v star and e one okay
so what is it saying it's saying that
you take some diagonal matrix you
conjugate it by unitaries
and you just look at the
first entry the one comma one entry in
this
in this conjugated matrix
what could it be
so
the task becomes to understand what
happens to
diagonal matrices when we conjugate them
by unitaries
so diagonal matrices are special types
of hermitian matrices
so
and when we look at the conjugation of
diagonal matrices by
unitary matrices we get
a different type of
a group structure which
i will refer to at the end of the proof
of this
but right now let's just do elementary
mathematics so the proof of this you can
ignore all the group theory and just
focus on elementary mathematics
if you like
uh so so what is the diagonal entry of
vdv star so the diagonal entry of v d v
star just by writing is let's say you
know
a i i
okay sorry this a has nothing to do with
that a this is probably just overload of
notation
so a i i
is
the sum
over j
of v i j lambda j v i j star this is
just what it means to be a diagonal
entry so we can rewrite this as v i j's
i mean the the
absolute value of v i j squared times
lambda j
now here we do us
we make a small observation
that if we denote this quantity vij
square by qij
then
because v was a unitary matrix q ends up
being a doubly stochastic matrix
okay so this is kind of the the the
uh one of the first uh
simple but important observations in
this
uh in this proof
so what this is this is a very basic
fact it says that if you have a unitary
matrix and you look at the hadamard
product which is just taking the entries
you know score
i mean essentially conjugating and then
multiplying each ij entry then the
matrix that you get is a doubly
stochastic matrix and dub what's a
double stochastic matrix it has come up
earlier but let me just recall
it's a matrix where every row sum and
every column sum is equal to one
and q gets this property because u u
star is identity and u star u is also
identity
so
incidentally the set of all doubly
stochastic matrices is a polito
okay
this is a theorem of uh this is a very
old theorem i i uh you know i don't know
who this is but at least 100 years old
um and this polytroph is called the
burkhoff molito
moreover the famous burkhoff von neumann
theorem tells us that this polytope
which is the set of all w stochastic
matrices
is a convex combination of all
permutation matrices so what's a
permutation matrix a permutation matrix
is uh over l and elements is
an n crosshand matrix where in the
uh
in each row and each column there is
exactly one one and rest zeros and
the entry in the i though the one in the
ith
uh row is exactly the
position where a permutation sigma maps
i2
so i guess everyone here has seen these
objects
and this theorem is also not a big
surprise this is the most basic
clearance and
in optimization discrete optimization
matchings for example get a lot of the
nice properties because of this
structure
so what we have proved in this
in this set of uh
through this set of equalities is the
following
that any unitary v for any unitary v
if i look at the diagonal
of v d v star
so i should remark that d is a diagonal
matrix but v d v star is not necessarily
a diagonal matrix okay it could be a
general matrix with
non-diagonal entries
so unitaries don't preserve the
diagonalness
um and that's why we're even looking at
it
so what we have
proved in these two lines of equality is
that for any unitary v the diagonal of v
d v star
is
q lambda
uh
where q is some doubly stochastic matrix
which we know from burkhoff uh one
neumann theorem can be written as a
convex combination of permutation
matrices
so in essence
you can write the diagonal as a convex
combination of permutations of lambda so
you apply that corresponding permutation
matrix and lambda so you get a
permutation of lambda itself these are
now vectors in
um
so this is an n cross n matrix and we
have a projection map
which takes this n cross and matrix and
maps it to a vector of length n
so this is another polytope uh let's
call it p sub lambda which is the
following polytope you take a vector
lambda
you look at all its permutations uh
which is uh by action of the group
symmetric group sn
so you're going to get n factorial not
necessarily distinct vectors
and you take the convex l of all these
vectors
so this polytube lives in n dimensions
okay the burkha foreign polytope lives
in n square dimensions
and in some sense the burkha von neumann
uh sorry the work of polytube is some
kind of an extend you know extension of
this
uh this polygon
so this actually is sufficient for us to
get the result now that to prove the
main theorem
so what we can see from here is so we
haven't proved uh uh yeah so what we
have proved is
uh the diagonals of
diagonal matrices conjugated by
unitaries
uh live inside a polytope which we call
p lambda okay
so so p lambda is a bigger set in some
sense so we get this inequality
the minimum over this set of unitaries
is at least the minimum over a set of
vectors in p lambda
but this is
i mean so so so what is uh
so so this is fairly easy to see right
now we are have a linear optimization
problem over a polytope we know that the
solution will be at a vertex we know
what each vertex is
each vertex is
uh just some permutation of lambda
and we have to we are only picking up
the first entry of this permutation of
lambda so which permutation will
minimize this well the one that picks up
the smallest eigenvalue
so we we can solve this problem
straightforwardly using our
understanding of basic linear
optimization
and the other direction is uh not too
difficult i mean this is a minimum over
all permutation all sorry entry matrices
you can plug in a special one
that diagonalizes a and puts the first
eigenvalue in one comma one entry and so
you can get the other inequality and so
you are done
any questions about this uh
this proof
i don't know if many people have seen
this proof
[Music]
this is not the proof that you will be
taught in the class uh
if
you know where you would be proving this
theorem
okay so let's move on
so here's where uh uh
we'll try to make things a little bit
more interesting so we have this one
slide where we will now
start zooming out
and saying you know what really happened
here
so first of all uh this fact that we
proved that the you know the the the
uh the
projection of the dia
of
the projection of unitary conjugations
of a diagonal matrix
is contained in p lambda
the converse is also true that you get
exactly p lambda i mean and you get
nothing i mean
that you can go back which means that
for any vector v which is in the convex
cell of
permutations of lambda you can go back
and find a unitary such that this vector
is a diagonal of udu star the proof of
this is not particularly difficult
i would leave it as an exercise so the
first part is typically referred to as
the sure part of this theorem and the
second part is referred to as a horn
part theorem
so in in other words
what we have proved is that projection
onto the diagonal of all unity matrices
in the conjugation orbit of permission
of our mission is apolitol
okay so i've highlighted in in
uh you know words in red
which seem very accidental but these all
generalize so we can talk about
projection operators there is a way to
talk about diagonals there is a talk a
way to talk about conjugation and there
is a particular polygon
that will arise if you do this in full
generality
but we'll come to that and and you'll
see more of it in the second talk
moreover uh well this is a relatively
straightforward fact which we already
saw that
this is kind of the definition of p
lambda that the political p lambda is
just the convex hull
of not any set of vectors but
vectors which are generated very
systematically
you have this vector lambda
you apply
every possible permutation to this
lambda and then you look at the convex
hell of it
so
it may seem very coincidental that some
discrete group shows up so what i mean
you know this is not a particularly
uh a point worth mentioning at least you
know but but you will see that you know
there is the the the
the discrete group that arises is not at
all an accident
but with this shure horn theorem we can
already prove something a bit more
gentle than what we just proved so
instead of just the matrix e1 which was
the diagonal
matrix with one and zeros you can prove
this theorem for any diagonal d prime
okay
the optimization problem over a unitary
group
uh reduces to
some kind of optimization problem over
the permutation group
the permutations are special types of
unitary so this is important
so permutations are
so this this group here sn
is a discrete subgroup of um
so what will be what will we see in part
two
in part two we are going to see a
generalization of the sherhold theorem
to compact leak and this is
uh
this is a famous uh an important theorem
called costanz convexity theorem
conjugation uh will be replaced by
something which will be called a joint
action diagonal matrices uh will
generalize to something called maximal
taurus or
if you're working in the lee algebra
it's a carton certainly cartons of
algebra and and projection which
implicitly uses some kind of an inner
product
uh will require a very carefully chosen
uh bilinear form called the killing form
and what happens to the permutation
group this is where this object's
so-called valence group arrives
so you're going to see all this
stuff hopefully in part two
but the punch line uh would be that
linear optimization or adjoint orbits of
b groups reduces to linear optimization
over convex polygons
so this is
the the generalization that you get once
you're ready to learn a little bit of
lead group theory
okay so since i'm going to switch to the
proof of the second theorem i'll take a
30 second break to see if anybody has
questions at this point
i have a question um can we generalize
this to infinite dimensional settings
infinite dimensional settings um the eye
value problem is still well defined
all right it's a good question so
um
well these i mean i yeah so i mean i
guess i i do use finite dimensional and
compact groups here uh but
yeah so i i i i would say i don't know
uh it's a good question i mean i'll
think about it or
um that's all i can say at this point
so saying no would not be because i
don't know if you cannot do that yeah
sure
question
suppose we optimize over tensor as
opposed to quadratic form which is now a
hard problem
but can it also be represented as
reformulated as some convex optimization
problem which would be presumably
complex over very
large dimension or exponentially large
dimension but is there some
notion of this in for tensor
optimization
um
so i think all of this stuff generalizes
when you start allowing uh more
complicated representations than just
the ad joint action
and there are experts probably sitting
in the room uh
like
cole and
avi who would probably
feel free to answer that question of
your code
so do you mean like something like v
tensor b tensor v yeah against something
else
against the tensor so a maximize a inner
product b times and b times b it's a
hard problem yeah but
whether there's some you know structure
like this yeah i don't know so i guess
the thing
which i i don't fully understand about
this is what kind of linear functions
you
have to optimize over
the android orbit maybe
the answer might depend on that yeah i'm
not sure but now but
i i doubt there's a central
generalization that looks like this
you don't have the linear algebra you
don't have diagonalization with pencils
and i yeah
i don't know any and i suspect it would
be
so more complex if you go to higher
damage
so i would also point uh the
questionnaire to the works of burn
stumpfields and others
uh so often
i mean they have a slightly different
approach to this which is you know
so they convexify these objects so
instead of working i mean so maybe it is
actually a hard object to optimize over
so one thing you could do is to
convexify it and that's where this term
orbital comes in so orbital is just a
convex cell of an orbit so that becomes
the convex
object and so so i mean in theoretical
computer science we do this all the time
we have some set or which is probably
hard to optimize so we take the convex
health
and we optimize over here and then we
try to figure out how to round it so
you're not going to get an exact
solution probably
but
this is something
uh that at least a couple of us have
been thinking about how to
uh all those stuff i'm not sure this is
addressing your question i just wanted
to make this remark
the first thing we used was a special
seal
there is no analog in the higher
protector
yeah
that's also true
okay so uh
i will continue to this next uh
next result
uh which is probably going to be even
more mysterious than this one
uh
so here my goal is to prove uh that if i
integrate this exponential density over
this
unitary orbit of e1 i get this
like uh you know a summation and not
just any summation it's just a summation
which involves n terms
and you can you know as a
as a theoretical computer scientist you
would be delighted because this is
something you can compute exactly and
efficiently
in
in any sense of the word
you might imagine
so this proof has a
again a few steps and these steps are
very similar okay so the first step
reduces this problem
um
of integrating a linear function or
sorry a exponential function or log
linear function
to an integral
over
the
n-dimensional probability simplex so
what is this object n-dimensional
probability when delta-1
this is the set of all non-negative
vectors
in n dimensions with sum up to one
that's why i call it that's the that's
the reason why the one is there
and why is this true
this is not an obvious fact
this is true because of formula such as
you know bombier is formula i mean this
goes by many names uh
but roughly speaking
it says
that you can take any polynomial in the
entries of this matrix x
so these x 1 1 x 2 2 are
uh you know some so so this is the uh
diagonal the one one entry of x this is
the two comma two entries and so on so
if i look at
the diagonal of x and i look at
some i mean these mis you can for this
talk you can think miss at just one but
there could be other integers as well
uh other positive integers as well
so if you integrate a monomial like this
you get a similar monomial over
the corresponding measure which is i
mean the mu delta 1 is just a leg
measure
over delta one so this is this measure
that we already know
so this is a this requires some complex
analysis some basic complex analysis to
prove uh it's not difficult but i i'm
not i mean you can see the proof of this
in the notes but
but if you believe this then because the
exponential can be written as some kind
of uh
you know taylor series involving such
polynomials you can recover this
uh this integer
exactly it's a limiting form so you you
get a whole bunch of equalities
you you combine them and you add them up
and you get this formula
okay so it seems pretty bizarre and
i mean doesn't look at all like this was
generalized at least when i first saw
this
so how do we then do uh you know how do
we go from okay so it's still some
exponential density on the simplex so
it's not entirely obvious how do we do
this how do we integrate this so we move
from one continuous set to another
continuous set well this is convex so in
principle
we could invoke the heavy machinery of
uh
you know works in theory computer
science such as low loash and shimanovic
and vampala and khanna and others and
saying you know this is just a lock
concave function or a political what is
the problem basically i mean just use
that technology to do that well we don't
have to do that first of all and even if
you were to do that you would not get
this log one or epsilon type of results
which i think ah we mentioned
but we don't have to do any of that so i
mean this is high school or uh you know
or undergraduate mathematics which i'm
going to show you
so if you take this integral
here
and just open it up
so you're separating out each coordinate
so this is how we do integration uh
where we take a domain and we go
coordinate by coordinate
and and see what this formula looks like
it turns out that you can just view this
formula as
convolution of certain functions
so this star is uh
the
you know f and g let's say are two real
valued functions that convolution
is defined as this integral of this
shifted uh
product
and
you can prove uh
in a line or so that this integral is
nothing but the convolution and so on so
what if it's a convolution and if you
have a convolution we know of nice
things in particular laplace transforms
come in i guess this is all stuff
i studied in my
undergraduate and i thought never
thought this would be useful
but here it is
um
so when you have a convolution of
functions
you can compute its laplace transform so
in particular for the exponential
the laplace transform is something very
simple so e to the minus lambda 1 t is
laplace transform is 1 over s plus
lambda 1.
and for convolutions you're just going
to get a product
so we can do this trick that we can view
we can apply the laplace transform and
then take the inverse laplace transform
i mean all this needs some justification
but all of this can be done
and literally in three uh three lines of
proof you can recover
that
you get this summation which is a
summation over exponentials involving
lambda i's
well if you're if you do it carefully
you will also recover the cis exactly
and they will match
uh
uh you know what is written here
but those of you who are
already ahead maybe already realized
that these these these constants here
uh are you know this is so one over
lambda i minus lambda g kind of term
this is a van der bond
a determinant of the van der waal matrix
so determinants are lurking behind here
it's not obvious in this proof
polytopes are lurking behind so you know
what is the determinant anyway
determinant is a summation over the
symmetric group so uh
so all these objects are here but if you
see this proof you only maybe get a hint
that these things are here
so what is going on here
it's okay if you didn't follow all the
steps of this proof i mean the point of
this slide was to show you that the
proofs are indeed pretty elementary and
can be done without any reference to any
symmetries
so let's consider a slightly more
general problem which is what at least
my original motivation was
so
instead of looking at the orbit of just
e1 we can look at the orbit of any
hermitian matrix lambda
uh orbit like the unitary conjugation
orbit
and i can ask this question
about can we sample from exponential
densities on this orbit now this
question becomes much more interesting
and it has
a surprising number of applications in a
variety of areas
so
i guess uh originally we arrived at it
uh with jonathan when we were looking at
uh
maximum entropy distributions over
continuous manifolds
but we realized soon enough that this
object is central to many different uh
areas and statistics these densities are
go by the name of
matrix lonzone or bingham densities
because this is some kind of a
robust version of minimum eigenvalue
problem or or some kind of a principal
component analysis which is a kind of
eigenvalue problem
it has applications in differential
privacy
this was observed by kamalika chaudhary
swarvatyan cena
these functions actually show up in
understanding the isotropic constant of
convex bodies in particular works of
bromo uh uh which inspired the work of
klartag
and and subsequently the work of uh
sebastian bubeck and ronan eldan
who studied entropic barrier
which is nothing but densities like this
which which which then the question of
whether we can compute these quantities
uh was not
not clear
so
yeah i mean these these results will
hopefully be discussed in the workshop
in november or december
i don't want to go into that but there
is there is a lot of uh different things
where such things are applicable
let me do a uh let me do a the same
trick that i did for uh for for
e1
i'm just going to convert it into an
integral over the unitary group okay
so
so if i plug in
if i take a unitary u and i plug in uh i
replace
you know x by
u lambda u star
i get this rather strange looking uh
strange looking integral e to the trace
of y u lambda u star
it turns out that this density
is goes by the name of harish chandra
injects and super density on unitary
groups
and it has a whole set of applications
uh in quantum field theory quantum
gravity string theory
random matrix theory and free
probability i think terry tao has a very
nice blog post about it in case you want
to read about this
so
this
question that we asked about sampling
from an exponential density on a unitary
orbit
is exactly the same as sampling from the
hcid density
um
and an amazing result and a very deep
result
so
by harish chandra
and and subsequently independently
discovered by itzhiksan and zuber
is that these integrals have these
expressions in terms of determinants
so this is uh
this is just the matrix with i comma jth
entry is e to the y i lambda j so you
can assume without loss of generality
essentially that y and lambda are both
diagonal
and given by y 1 2 y n and lambda 1 to
lambda
so it is uh
yeah when we were working on this
problem and kind of we uh
we needed something like this
it was a bit i mean i must say the first
feeling i always remember i mean this
the fact that this integral is a
determinant uh
definitely raises the question why is it
a determinant i mean it could be
it could have a formula but that formula
doesn't necessarily have to involve a
determinant
and it was not obvious at all in the
rank one case that i described in the
previous slide that it is a determinant
but you can show that it is also a
determinant
if you really care about it
the bottom line is that these are
efficiently computable formulas for some
really
unwieldy looking integrals
but natural in the context of
various disciplines
in fact the history of this formula is a
little bit uh you know goes backward in
time harish chandra who was trying to
uh
to to to
extend the theory of fourier analysis to
semi-simple league groups came up with
what is called the etsy formula the
harishchandra formula
which is a strict and a major
generalization of this cic format
so inz discovered this special case for
the unitary groups much later than
harish chandra discovered the the
formula and i hope uh jonathan will
mention this formula in this talk
and it is not at all um
a miracle that determinants show up in
fact these integrals are integrals over
league groups compactly groups and to
every compact league group there is an
associated
whale group which is the finite
counterpart of it so the summations are
signed summations or avail groups
and uh it turns out that for several
interesting groups like the unitary
group it's a single determinant you can
look at other groups like symplectic
group uh it's a it's a sum of small
number maybe two or three determinants
and you can also look at the uh you know
orthogonal group they're also it
it boils down to determinants there's no
theorem that it'll always be a
determinant but
uh for all cases that we care about
and for those of you know the lee class
i mean the classification theorem of d
group there are really three major
classes of
uh lead groups so we have a determinant
formula for all of them and then there
are these exceptional leap groups
where these are just finite
anyway so all that uh
[Music]
you will hopefully
be interested in knowing
and the proof of the cig formula is not
the same as the one i presented before
the reason is that simplex has a lot of
structure its coordinates are
essentially independent the moment you
go to higher uh even rank two orbits
orbits of rank two matrices
you you you uh
the structure breaks down
and for a long time i mean i should tell
you this for a long time jonathan and i
were trying to extend these results
using the moment map
um and studying the push forward of
these densities under the moment map it
turns out that these densities are much
uh are not very well understood
it turns out that there is another
projection formula
which really does the following it takes
a matrix it looks at all
principal
uh minors let's say one cross 1 minus 2
plus 2 minus n cross n minus computes
eigen values of each of these matrices
and that's the mapping
so this
this is a different mapping which maps
our unitary matrix to a a higher
dimensional space and not just the
diagonal this is the rayleigh map
uh eigen values interlaced and so on so
it's described by some very nice
combinatorics and
you know it's called the rayleigh
polytope
it is a polytope it's called the
rayleigh polytope and once we identify
the right mapping we can recover a proof
of the cig formula at least in this
setting
so the bottom line is that integrals
over and joined orbits of lead groups
reduce to finite determinant-like
summations
this is again a fairly general
uh
uh statement which can be made precise
okay so i think i'm at the end of my
time so i'll conclude and then take all
the questions that you might have
so in this talk uh hopefully
through these examples that i presented
or some very natural problems over
orbits of
you know lead group actions you got a
sense that uh
the algebra and analysis kind of the
interplay between algebra analysis and
the proofs
more generally continuous symmetries can
be useful to design
optimization and sampling algorithms
over non-convex manifolds in fact
this is
uh this was also uh
kind of the core conceptual message of
the talks before
uh non-convexity is just uh
you know it's it's just anything that is
not convex but there may be tractable
cases of non-complex optimization and
sampling
and
a very interesting class of such objects
are non-convex objects which have
symmetries
like orbits
and often these results are obtained
through deep and hidden connections
and and the role symmetries plays reduce
the problem from manifolds to polytopes
and subsequently to some discrete
problems so it's really uh fascinating
all this stuff
there is a growing body of work uh so
again a partial list uh you know i think
um
much has been talked about already i
mean the work of uh gurus olivia
victorson who started this
uh their line of work
and applications to
uh very far removed problems in
complexity theory such as identity
testing
um
you know developing methods for
optimizing
[Music]
functions or geodesic sets or
geodesically convex optimization first
order method second order method some
really nice series of work i'm not
citing all the papers here
uh brass camp leave constant something
that uh
uh
you know it's it's it's it's something
in mathematics and again trying to
understand or compute these constants
has interesting connections with
symmetries
um i think i already mentioned some of
these other applications like interior
point methods uh
uh computing a certain type of quantum
entropy which is uh something that
jonathan and i did in a paper in 2020
and more recently we discovered some
connections with physics and the matrix
theory and privacy
and there is i'm sure there are words
i'm missing uh
there is uh
so apologies in advance if i
missed your work
so the part two of this uh series would
be lead theory basics uh
and extending or at least giving you a
sense of how to even formulate these two
results that i presented
in the general setting
with this uh
i would like to thank you for your
attention and i'll take any questions
details
of this talk and the next can be
uh you can view them in this archive
paper
thank you
questions
so for the integral formula can you do
that over the
of the orthogonal matrices
are you using the complex numbers in
some essential way
yes it is uh it's a very good question
actually so that's one of the
open problems
i mean much of this
uh
so the complex numbers are essential at
least in the proof of hci z for blocks
so when you
move towards let's say
the symmetric set of symmetric matrices
we don't have such beautiful formulas
unfortunately
but that's something we are i mean
that's something we are trying to think
about we are already thinking about it
so i'd be very happy to talk more to
whoever asked this question
another question all right actually to
bootstrap onto under that nation can you
give a sense of what actually breaks
down is is this bombier style formula
that breaks down for the symmetric case
absolutely yeah
but that's where you need complex uh i
mean those integrals are over complexes
yeah the push forwards measure don't
are not so nice anymore when you're
working over
reels and i'm sure jonathan being there
can
uh tell you much more about this
yeah so so i do think that the the you
can get some kind of integral formula
it's just this it's this push forward
that it's the measure that becomes a
problem the integral i think you can get
some kind of determinant type thing it's
just it doesn't it doesn't kind of lead
to this like nice measure on this
on israeli polytope like it does in the
complex case
so it's not uniform yeah so yeah i don't
think so
so i think uh you know what what he's to
parse what he's saying is that there is
a mapping that takes you from this orbit
to a polytope and then you need to go
back also if you sample something in
this polytope you need to go back and
this going back uh
becomes messy
or are probably not
uh possible in other settings
like a change of variables formula or
something is that sort of that's right
it's not explicit yeah yeah so this is i
mean so so this is very natural that it
showed up in random matrix too i mean
you know so i if anybody has studied uh
uh you know
this stuff you know that there are three
types of ensembles right i mean and and
the best one is the gue the gaussian
unitarian sample
and then the other ones are slightly
more ugly to deal with and that's
exactly the same kind of difficulty you
experience here
thank you yeah so uh thank you for the
talk i mean i'm speaking for from very
limited knowledge about this but um you
know so when you're translating the
problem the original problem to you know
the political problem let's say i mean
at some point you you use
deep inequality or deep theorem so i
mean at least in the examples that you
were showing you know say the the
spectral theorem you you use at some
point or uh this bomberic formula
and
i'm curious i mean um
these are things that you have in hand
that then you know
you know you have intuition as to what
is the structure you're looking for and
then you you know you you have this uh
other theorems
or
you know
how does this work i mean could it be
the case that these theories that you
precisely need to make this connection
are more difficult i'm just curious in
general about you know how how things
uh work here
i would appreciate any comment thank you
so i would be uh lying if i say that
this is how i viewed the the world a
year ago
i mean often we got these results by
some series of coincidence
and then when we reflect upon them we
start seeing lots of patterns and then
we uh
you know
so i
maybe jonathan has a different point of
view here i mean this is all joint work
with him but uh from my point of view
there is still a lot of mystery in how
we go from
certain problems to their
you know to to to
convex
into the convex world i mean that is
already illustrated in this fciz thing
where for a very long time we were stuck
with the moment map
it's not like things are not known about
the moment map i mean what happens to
the push forward measure of an
exponential density in an orbit under
the moment map
things are known it is known that it is
piecewise polynomial uh but
it's not as
yeah and but nobody knows what these
polynomials are going to be so whereas
you know by going to a different uh
different uh
different
uh
way to project the matrix into you know
you get a different set of uh yeah you
got a very nice easy structure so
but i learned jonathan comment on that
as well
at least at least the way i think of the
bombierian or product showing a bobby
gary formula showing up here was yeah
more like coincidence i mean it was we
didn't really know what else to do and
that sort of worked
uh and then that didn't generalize so we
tried to find some other things that
might i mean that was kind of that's
kind of how i remember
um and i don't i still don't really know
the whole picture like
they're they're theorems and they're
like you know ways that this stuff will
generalize in the next talk but
beyond that i you know i start grasping
again
so
maybe it's not so surprising that
when you look at objects that are closed
under conjugation the result will be
dependent only on the idea part
so in both results that's what happened
what the defendants might be may not be
obvious
uh in the first case it's pretty obvious
in the second it's quite you know maybe
mysterious
but at least you expect some formula
that depends on the other part
yeah at least so far you can guess
i mean we i mean just to contrast we
don't have formulas involving gaussian
integrals right i mean so it is uh
it is a bit uh surprising that we have
like clear formulas and and that also
involving determinants
so that we can demystify uh because you
know the fact that determinants arise is
because the veil group has
some structure
but you know i mean to what extent all
this stuff is true i think this is a
work on progress
um
but i feel quite positive uh
and also i think uh i mean i really
appreciate the work that avi and his set
of co-authors are doing which is
i would say a level uh
uh further because they are looking at
general representations and there i
think there is even more scope of
discovering structure
okay that's it let's uh thank you very
nice talk
thank you